hello welcome to this video playing
Aladdin yeah last game i won due to
disconnection opponent just disconnected
after move sometimes you just get points
gifted to you so Aladdin is going for
this one did you screw up the move water
okay I can't play before but that's not
really my my usual way of playing it but
should be 70 also don't like okay anyway
I didn't meet I need to get going him
yeah and that's it I don't like it hmm
and what to move for what I did I screw
up there what did you know yeah okay
this is this is not a very nice position
it's got some pressure maybe a five
something that's good for right now
didn't do it I came home I wonder have
Knight a5 as possible sacrificing that
pawn I think I'm going for it I don't
like this at all with this knight on d5
and so on um and I might have some
compensation chat okay don't consider it
even I guess
we've taken before okay so six a bit of
an annoying pin here but I don't really
see something terrible happening to me
yeah take I guess I'll take ya yeah not
happy not happy with this position but
maybe it's still kind of okay might be
three coming up
Kim what to do here rook c8 meaning
hmm not nice
something that we need to isn't all that
clear yeah okay I'm going to try for
this counter play with my dear for my
pledge III yeah if five could be also
leading into total disaster i have to
take that oh my god that wasn't helpful
and so what now okay time is of the
essence IAM not so great this this break
okay ideas ideas ideas Queenie 8 could
be something protecting that Paul
Queenie to I have would be true i guess
or taking can also just take my
and now he's taking time it's not an
easy position definitely not maybe he's
playing some don't know some age for
stuff my g5 action wasn't all that
productive but ok it's catching up
that's cool maybe he feels like I got
interrupted he wants to give me the time
back which is actually what happened ok
so I cannot really complain about some
time stuff he returned all the time
what's going on him it's really a bit
bit strange some Quincy tune
night always so c 5 2 d 3 would be cool
something like that it's also
potentially deformed under- center oh do
I just lose that that okay it's not
maybe all that terrible if I lose it
doesn't have a good square actually 93
in size I'm coming up so 95 or covering
it looks wrong
we can still take oh I didn't see that
one coming time morning okay 93 queen
here I can also just take actually let's
take it where are you going
check check 12 3 wait check wow that
still looks kind of weird check check
check check check check check check
black it's all right what's import to
finish oh my god now Kim of course it's
a total win but then somehow somehow let
him in down check I should just take I
just take the bishop come on and have 25
second I totally lost my composure here
gets funnier the engine here to draw I
cannot avoid a draw now ah it's awful
losing the shine I'd be a costly yeah i
know i'm lost him he's got this attack
going and i cannot do anything about it
it's pretty awful ok so yea yea Raj here
I had this lost roughly 80 seconds now
yeah somehow he gave me all the time
back I mean here white is just
why it's just not in very good shape i
guess yeah I want that material and I
should just win the game of course but
this was a good this was a good try
actually have to say here this year it's
not all that easy yeah I can of course
take I mean but I wasn't sure that this
is winning you know maybe it is have I
get a 3 I thought this counter attack
would be stronger and it proved to be
winning will not be six years ok chan
chan so vacuum both sides are blended
down Yung probably I should go for the
technical technical wave just yeah just
play this oops sorry and I just wasn't
sure if I'm winning but ok if I could
calculate further check I probably win
this and should it should be there
should be the win still the tricky check
yea the deep pond makes so make some
noise down engine gives win probably it
is anyway there were many blunders but
ok the always a bit tricky if I'm
interrupted in the middle of the game
voice it's rarely ends well ok well
thanks for watching